Summa wrestling there's a game of
seconds
however there's months of training that
go within those seconds imagine it's
like an earthquake that's building and
building and building and all of a
sudden there's this huge explosion all
at one time
that's what C was I'm really just a
normal guy I'm a husband I'm a father of
three I'm the director of technology for
the County Office of Education I'm also
an American somewhere outside
Summa has a long history in Japan some
people trace it back up to 1500 or 2000
years but it's essentially you know
wrestling where you either want to push
your opponent out of the ring or knock
your opponent to the ground
people have an image but sumo wrestlers
are basically just bumping bellies and
wobbling around and as you can see from
the practice here nothing's further from
the truth
we're always amazing he basically came
out of nowhere he showed up to the 2014
US whom open and blew everyone's mind he
beat every single American opponent he
was almost no training he's already the
number one American to be a competitive
sumo wrestler you need to train hard
whether I'm stretching with them
powerlifting whether I'm working out
with with rocks I'm always looking for
the edge the thing that really brought
me to sumo was the fact that there was
culture and sport all kind of mixed in
one it seemed like a perfect fit for
example when you stomp the ground you're
ridding the area of bad spirits and when
you make your first clap you're waking
up the gods you know he is a gentle
giant and he doesn't want to hurt
anybody and sumos great that way because
you know they're just trying to get each
other out of the ring they're not trying
to knock each other out or really hurt
hurt one another
I think sumo has that camaraderie
fraternity aspect to it
you know we're banging heads we're going
at it at the end of it there's still
this high level of respect I guess as a
pacifist that definitely appeals to me